This morning, the United States struck
Iran in a counterattack for the missiles
launched against US bases uh in a
counterattack for the United States
striking the MLRS that Iran was using to
lay mines in the Straight of Hormuz.
Yes, they they were using a rocket
launcher system to deliver mines that
launch out of the end of a rocket tip
with a parachute to sit at the bottom of
the straight of Hormuz to blow up ships.
We talked about the details of that in a
different video, but now we need to know
that Iran has responded to the United
States strikes by sending 13 ballistic
missiles to um Jordan, targeting what
appeared to be a US base camp uh Titan
in Jordan, right on the Saudi and Jordan
uh border.
And apparently 10 of these 13 missiles
fired from Iran were intercepted per the
Jordani uh air defenses and their
military
and three of them did end up impacting
the ground. Now Jordan says those
impacts occurred away from population
centers and in essentially rural areas.
Well, this camp happens to be in a rural
area. So a lot of folks are wondering
okay was the camp hit and was anyone
injured at the camp.
US operations uh or to US officials have
claimed that there have been no injuries
at the attack and no quote or from the
attack and quote no major damage. Okay.
So this has led a lot of people to
speculate, okay, why potentially are we
seeing medevac helicopters flying around
there? Are Israeli medevac helicopters
coming there as well? Those all reported
as speculative. Uh the United States
suggests no casualties. Other people
say, uh, if we read between the lines,
there is quite a bit of a chance we
ended up having some form of damage that
could have hurt somebody, especially
since the United States, at least
reportedly, has been trying to obscure
the amount of war casualties that have
occurred. These are according to
multiple different uh news services. Who
knows ultimately what ends up being
true. Hopefully, nobody was injured. But
the argument from Jordan is they
intercepted 10 of 13 missiles. Three of
them hit the ground. We hear from Al
Jazzer that there was uh no major damage
which is an interesting word to use
because then it just sort of implies
that was there some damage right here's
the report from uh you know 27 minutes
ago no injuries or major damage follow
US uh attack okay all right fine so
hopefully we could take them for their
word that there were no injuries and
hopefully there was no major damage uh
and that ultimately the Iranian
retaliation was uh solved or absorbed.
Essentially, the problem with this is
Donald Trump has argued that if the
Iranians retaliate, then we will once
again retaliate against their strikes.
And so we have this classic tit fortat
situation going on while Russia is
allegedly working with Iran on helping
them get to a cruise missile that they
can use to attack land targets with more
accuracy and speed and attack US ships.
The ballistic missiles they use now are
fast, but they're I mean they they fly
at a fast speed, but over a long
distance they they can still take 15 to
20 minutes to arrive. And because they
have a relatively stable trajectory,
some of them have lately been able to
adjust their trajectory as they come in
for a strike, making it a little harder
to intercept. But because they generally
follow an arc pattern, they're a lot
easier to intercept than, let's say, a
cruise missile, which might fly really
low above the ground to avoid radar
detection and ultimately strike a target
significantly faster than a ballistic
missile could. uh with less visibility.
Apparently, the Financial Times is now
reporting on this that it's actually
Russia that is engaging Iran to secretly
develop a supersonic cruise missile.
Supersonic cruise missile is the key
there. They already have supersonic
ballistic missiles, but again, those are
the predictable ones. Supersonic cruise
missile is more dangerous. And if this
is true, if this is really what's being
developed, then it could give Iran an
edge in anti-tank and anti-ship weaponry
that maybe we might not be able to
intercept as well. Apparently, a
contract was signed with Russia back in
November of 2023.
Uh and it's possible that Ukraine has
really encouraged Russia to deepen ties
with China, Iran, and North Korea,
accepting the to now transfer not just
defensive weaponry to Iran, but also
offensive weaponry to Iran. China
supplying weapons and satellites as
well, which helps Iran with their
targeting. Uh Russia has supplied man
pads, the Russian Verba systems. Uh, so
we are expanding and deepening Russia's
involvement with Iran, especially since
Iran already manufactures a lot of their
shy drones in Russia.
This could potentially make Iran more
capable of threatening US aircraft
carriers or other warships in the
region. So, this is one heck of an
allegation here that they could use
ramjet engines inside of cruise missiles
to uh attack the United States with a
new qualitative style weapon that hasn't
been seen before from Iran. Now the
usage of qualitative uh which is right
here for Iranians this would give them a
new qualitative strategic weapon to me
is a little bit alarming because if we
look at what the IRGC's uh Galibbuff
said today uh well technically not the
IRGC's but Galibbuff who's been one of
the primary negotiators uh for Iran if
we look at what he said today he
actually argued that the United States
should anticipate the following The
enemy should know that in the next
rounds of war, we will have greater
superiority both qualitatively and
quantitatively. In other words, we'll
have more numbers and better weapons if
we keep going tit for tat. Which is
interesting because it's the same word
that was used here qualitatively on a
new strategic weapon system that could
threaten US Navy vessels. I don't know,
maybe that's a coincidence. But the
point is, we're kind of going in the
wrong direction here. Things are getting
worse. Not only is there now talk about
this uh these sort of ballistic missiles
that were intercepted, there's also talk
about another uh drone attack against
Bahrain. This is actually and apparently
now Kuwait is literally as I'm recording
this also responding to a drone attack.
Take a look at this. We've got uh
minutes ago here Iran's army says it
carried out a wave of drone attacks on
radar installations in areas of Bahrain
where it says US forces are stationed.
According to a statement by Iran's uh
TASM news agency, the army said the
strikes were part of the 29th phase of
Operation Thunder, the military
campaign, this is a key base in the Gulf
for helicopter maintenance, drone
components, and reconnaissance aircraft,
the Iranian military claimed. And in
addition to that, if we scroll up a
little bit more, what do we got right
here? Kuwait's army says the country's
air defenses are currently responding to
attacks by hostile drones which is
linked to Iranian aggression opposed by
Kuwaiti armed forces said that
explosions were heard and uh those
explosions that were heard were the
result of air defenses intercepting the
drones.
Uh I'm also getting that in the wire
feeds that Kuwait air defenses are now
actively responding to a hostile threat.
Keep in mind you can see that sort of
wire feed if you want directly in our
Meet Kevin app on desktop or mobile. Uh
you can simply download the app in the
Apple or Android app store. Meet Kevin.
Just type that in. Sign up for the app.
If you're a course member, you could use
the course member email you signed up
with and you get more features, but
there are plenty of free features. And
then if you want, you could use the web
app after you sign up and unlock it by
doing step one and two. And the web app
is at app.mekevin.com.
And then you can kind of look at some of
this information that we're documenting
as well, which uh and and our
references, citations, and and more
research than we can really talk about.
Uh now this is very interesting because
if we're now escalating with types of
weaponry and expanding out fanning out
where uh we are being attacked as the
United States uh and where the United
States is attacking Iran allegedly
attacking a wedding, killing potentially
four individuals including a child along
with uh hurting about 35 others at a
wedding. That was one of the
allegations. Vice versa, we have an
allegation that Iran is claiming that
they have killed numerous American
soldiers. We do not have cor cooperation
of that. This is a here's a very kind of
rudimentary and relatively poor
translation, but uh this is where they
say that uh America is a child killing
regime and as a result of the American
attacks, the IRGC has issued uh a wave
of punishment on the base camp Titan.
There's some translation errors here. uh
located on the coast of the Gulf of
Akuba. Uh I probably screwed that up.
Akaba. Uh neutralizing a large number of
American forces and destroying several
important facilities and enemy attack
helicopters.
Some of this could be propaganda. The
United States is saying nobody was
injured. Iran saying they've killed
numerous American forces. Both sides
have been known to say things that are
halftruths. And that makes it a little
bit more difficult. Uh so where do we
sit now? Well, now we sit yet again in a
place where we probably have oil futures
uh that are rising now, but that also
expected to continue uh tomorrow, which
is not great. Uh and yields also getting
more aggressive. Take a look at uh the
futures market which just opened up. We
are now just 0.4 basis points away from
4.8 8 on the 10-year. And if we look at
uh oil, we're sitting over 95 on Brent.
Uh and if we jump on over to the odds of
an interest rate hike now from the
Federal Reserve on September 16th, we
are now knocking on the door of well
loading the actual page. So, whenever
that actually loads would be nice. And
uh it's coming. It's still not coming.
Okay, fine. While that loads, let's go
look at Google Maps for Camp Titan. This
is Camp Titan. You can actually see the
four helipads. So, Iran is not wrong to
argue that helicopters are housed here.
And if they said there were airplanes
here, that would be wrong given that
there is no airfield here. Uh you just
have a helipad
platform with four helipads. Uh you can
see what appear to be, you know,
barracks right here. uh as well as uh
smaller roads, smaller uh work
facilities. An expansion occurring over
here with tents and framing. Looks like
aluminum uh wall framing here to expand
the facility. Containers, shipping, and
supplies over here as well as some
equipment. And you can see this does
look like a rural area. So, it wouldn't
be wrong for Jordan to have said that
these missiles struck a rural area. We
actually came down a little bit. Uh at
least on this estimate, we were as high
as 68% likely to see a rate hike. Uh and
we're now sitting at, if we round, 67%.
[music] 66.9 if we don't.
So that gives us a little bit more color
on the disaster that's going on in Iran.
Why not advertise [music] these things
that you told us here? I feel like
nobody else knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you. Kevin Praath there, [music]
financial analyst and YouTuber, Meet
Kevin. Always great to get your take.